erin nola gets to start it's his 11th of
the year has been really good throughout
his career but lately
last three starts era close to seven the
phillies lost seven consecutive nola
starts
swinging a miss dandy curveball two outs
you said it tom that is a a really good
curveball look at the depth of that
thing too how much it dropped
got that baby on the outside part but
look how much that ball dropped
they do swinging to miss a little slower
curve that time second strikeout for
nola
now brad miller with the bases loaded
one out
and ball four that forces in a run
that's a close pitch roman quinn will
score and the phillies take a
one-nothing lead wow that is the tenth
time he has walked in his career with
the bases loaded and like you said tom
this is a close pitch i mean this could
have gone either way philly's catching a
break by getting that
it's called a ball and
now you're looking at
with the way reese is swinging a bad
potential big inning
oh two pitch tonighter with a runner at
first
and he bumps it foul and gotcha
andrew knapp again
aguilar strikeout victim his first time
into center field that is going to get
down for a base in denver's rounding
third he'll score
and aguilar comes through he's caught
between first and second but nobody's
home marlon's tied things up another rbi
for jesus aguilar
did not go to the breaking ball decided
to go to the two-seam fastball didn't
get it far enough in and aguilar fights
it off into center field
good speed on the bases
their first knock of the night produces
their first run the ball two strikes
reaches out pops it out to right field
tagging it third at segura duvall's got
a good arm he's got six outfield assists
coming home with segura the throw to the
plate is cut off they throw to second
not in time to get miller and the
phillies take the lead it's two to one
sac fly for reese hoskins it's his 30th
rbi of the year
i mean that pitch was down and away and
if reece tries to pull it it's a double
play instead he flips it out into right
field and
trust the fact that
segura can score on it
and the one two
and he's down on strikes 94 on the
heater
four strikeouts for erin noah the 87th
pitch for aaron noah the inning
yeah the pitch to dickerson swinging a
miss he got it with a change up five
strikeouts for nola no runs one hit
breaking ball down and away
[Music]
oh better get it there swag it a miss
got him with a change up six strikeouts
for nola second time he's got now faro
diaz will be the hitter
sant diaz
you know they don't have a ton of power
in this lineup
center field
well
herrera is going back and he is there he
pulled it right off the top of the fence
what a play
oh double herrera just robbed eason diaz
of a home run the game is not going to
be tied the phillies will maintain the
lead
that was perfect technique by o'double
herrera
aaron knoll loves it i think everybody
should love it if you're on the philly's
side
that's high and it gets away from knapp
and duvall will move to third up to
second goes diaz
just unable to catch up to
100 mile an hour fastball up top top of
the glove and basic should score two now
one and two
is a base head in the right field one
run is in here comes the second and
bernie comes through
marlins take the lead of the eighth
that's the way you get it done john
bernie
how about it just continue to battle and
fight
finally gets something he can handle
and just enough to get it through on the
right side
great swing by bertie
good speed on the bases
the marlins finally have a lead again
wouldn't mind an extra run i bet
might get it right here past miller
birdie around third he'll score devers
has a rivie and it's a 4-2 marlins lead
that's the way you get it done young man
he found himself a lane he liked last
time up
line drive down that left field line
follows suit again picks up his second
hit tonight and some insurance for the
marlins
my goodness 97 miles an hour up out of
the strike zone
wow some quick hands huh well the
scouting report on him right baseball
america has him rated as the best hitter
for average in the marlin system so now
down two roman quinn will lead it off
against amy garcia the closer for the
marlins
no balls and two strikes to roman
and it hit him right in the leg
and now the tying run is coming up
matt joyce is out of the on deck circle
in there for a called strike three right
at the bottom of the zone now jimmy
picks up most of his strikeouts this
season now 14
on the four scene fastball got it back
in
it's kind of a pattern that the marlins
have used against the phillies tonight
especially all the lefties in the lineup
andrew mccutchen who was over five with
a couple of strikeouts in his career
against garcia
tonight over four with a couple of
strikeouts two and two segura waits on
deck garcia brings it home to mccutchen
swinging in the miss at 97.
two down
goes back with 97.
out number two here in the ninth one for
six a double
and a strikeout against garcia
oh for three tonight
was hit by a pitch in the third reached
on an error and scored in the fifth
quinn is the runner at first
segura the tying run
right back to garcia bobbles gathers
throws to first finishes it off it's a
marlins win
what a comeback win for the marlins